ouch the Mazda dealership wants over
$500 to make a spare key fob and tells
me to spend two hours of my time sitting
in their waiting room that's crazy you
need another key for your Mazda vehicle
my Mike with Tom's key compan I to show
you just how easy it is to make a spare
key without leaving home with the help
of tomsk key.com we've got solutions for
thousands of different Vehicles so come
check us out before we jump in the car
and show you what's going to happen be
sure you stick around to the end of the
video I'm going to call the Mazda dealer
ship and ask them how much they want to
rip me off for to make a spare key so
let's jump in the car okay we're going
to program today you've got to have one
working key that starts the engine in my
case that's this tile keyfinder it
doesn't have the buttons on it do not
have to work but it's got to be able to
start the engine and this is the spare
key we're going to program with the
yellow key tag there's one very
important thing with many mozda vehicles
you've got to get the right FCC ID
number on your spare key so stick around
later in the video I'm going to tell you
how to find that out but for now let's
get going programming okay we got to
fire up the app and then have to scan
the barcode with the serial number not
the help barcode on the
back okay there we go tells us some
important things you need a solid
internet connection we've got to have
all keys both existing and new have
repairing tool and no caution or warning
the aftermarket components may cause
problems so if you have an aftermarket
alarm system aftermarket remote start
things like that you might run into some
problems so so proceed at your own risk
okay let's look up our vehicle this is a
Mazda 3 and it's 2014 so right there
okay asking what kind of key we have
there's only one option with this
vehicle a smart key meaning you use a
start button so we got our smart key
looks like we need download a data pack
from
Mazda okay we're ready to go for Mazda
got to plug in the pairing tool you got
to find the OBD2 port to plug this in if
you don't know where that is don't worry
it's not too hard come down down to your
gas and brake pedal look up there you go
sometimes it'll be under a panel up here
but usually it's just pretty easy to
access so plug in to make your life a
little bit easier I recommend picking up
this optional extension cable then you
can see what's happening with the
programmer with this guy here we've got
to get our pairing made let's come into
our bluetooth settings okay once it's
paired we should see a green light turn
blue there we go we've got the
programmer paired and the app also
indicates it's paired okay timing is
everything on this so pay close
attention if things go too slow you may
have to start over at the beginning turn
on the ignition within 30 seconds so I'm
going to push the start button once
twice till the dash lights turn on and
the vehicle has power but the engine is
not running we got to have the original
key okay here's my original key we need
to start the engine stepping on the
brake engine has started
okay next this programmer is going to
connect to the VIN of the vehicle so
it's now tied to the VIN of this vehicle
you can only program keys for one
vehicle with one programmer but you can
program multiple Keys Turn Off the
ignition okay ignition is
off turn on the ignition don't press the
brake pedal so same thing I'm going to
click twice dashboard lights
up hit next important notes here this is
not going to erase existing keys and up
to six keys can be paired so we're going
to pair one it's communicating with the
vehicle all right pairing the first key
press for automatic transmission or
manual transmission you need to push the
brake and then put the smart key up
within 15 seconds Touch where the logo
would be notice it says we've got five
Keys currently pairing Keys it says we
now have six Keys turn the ignition off
within 30 seconds so this vehicle has
lots of keys already paired to it we now
have six in the world and you can stick
around the end to see one of the
problems I caused with one of those we
got to turn the ignition off here's our
newly paired key I'm pressing down the
brake I'm holding it up here for 3
seconds and then I'm going to
press it
on the engine fires up and key pairing
is complete
notice I've got a blinking security
light going still I'm going to turn off
the engine now I'm going to take my
original key I'm going to push the start
stop button with the original key hold
it down engine fires up
okay we go ahead and turn off the engine
now I'm going to take this newly paired
key I'm going to do the same thing hold
the brake put it up to the start stop
button fire up the
engine that little
procedure that flashing security light
has stopped okay now let's check and see
if the these guys work okay there's two
things we want to test if it starts the
engine and if the remote buttons work so
let's check the buttons first I get this
guy
unplugged
okay let's see if the buttons work
here's the original key locks and
unlocks the doors here's a new key locks
and unlocks the doors look at that isn't
that amazing okay to make sure they
start the engine we've got to get all
the keys out of the
vehicle set the keys away from the
vehicle and try to start the engine if I
try to start it now nothing happens and
so we know it's far enough away can't
sense any Keys notice I'm getting this
blinking red security
light okay is not working so now that we
know we've got the keys far enough away
we'll bring them back in one at a
time here's the original key obviously
it still needs to work boom fires up the
engine
beautiful let's get this out of the
vehicle okay now we've got the new key
Moment of
Truth fires up the engine look at that
we've got a spare key working for the
vehicle isn't that amazing can you
believe how easy that was to make a
spare key with this little programming
device from Tom's key company okay for
Key by photo key cutting service take
your key out you want to set it on you
want to have the key nice and flat as
you take the photos be sure you add Key
by photo key cutting service
to complete checkout upload those as you
make your order we use our key by photo
key cutting technology your new key will
arrive already cut fitting the vehicle
it's like magic isn't that
awesome okay let's call the Mazda
dealership and find out what they're
going to charge to make a spare key how
can I help you I'm trying to find out
how much it's going to cost to make
another key fob for A4 Mazda to give me
one moment okay awesome thanks just on a
hold now
how much do you think they're going to
quote about 500 bucks maybe it's
$400
$450 think I'm going on hold for few
minutes now they're somewhere around 400
bucks because the part of the remote is
like $230 and the labor is $190 what how
how long does that take takes about two
hours $190 to make the spare key said
plan on a couple hours down there it's
going to take half my day by the time I
drive down drive back the service guy
couldn't get the parts department to
answer let's see if I can get them to
answer I'm trying to find out how much
it costs for a key fob for a 2014 Mazda
okay look like the fob itself
26703 plus programming okay does that
include the keyblade the metal emergency
keyblade in it keyblade 30 304 all right
so what's that all add up to 297
2977 297 okay thank you so much for the
information I appreciate it so there you
have
$297 plus tax to get a new new key fob
from the Mazda dealership plus $190 on
top of that I spent 10 or 11 minutes on
the phone getting my quote and
appointment in order to get this new key
fob made can you believe the Mazda
dealership wanted over $500 to make a
spare key fob and they said it was going
to take two hours we saw how quick and
easy that was you can do it at home in
about 10 minutes and Save hours of time
hundreds of dollars come to tomsk
key.com and order your spare key and
programming kit today we make it super
easy to make spare keys without leaving
home and what's more we back everything
up with a full money back guarantee so
if you run into a problem come visit us
help. tomsk key.com where you can find
solutions to common problems and reach
out to our customer support team will'll
help troubleshoot and if for some reason
it still doesn't work for you no worries
ship it all back you'll get a full
refund it's that
easy I invited you to stick around to
see the problem I ran into a few days
ago here's what happened to me so we can
make sure it doesn't happen to you let
me back up quickly and just show you the
abbreviated version of programming this
key and how I found that I had the a bad
circuit board or the wrong fcci ID
number here we go here's the 5-second
version of me programming this
key okay that was it key pairings
complete now watch as I go to test this
key and see what happens take a look at
the buttons check the lock see it's not
unlocking the other ones all work but
this one didn't if we try to start the
engine with this let's get all the keys
out of the
vehicle okay this is the only key in the
vehicle now if I try to start the
engine it doesn't work now nothing
happens we just get the blinking green
light on the push button start and the
flashing red security light on the dash
look what happens if I hold it next to
the start
button the start button lights up green
and we get a green security light so
that's kind of interesting because it
allows me to start the engine well
here's what's happening the chip inside
this key has been programmed and it can
be sensed by the vehicle computer when
the key is held right next to the start
button that's very helpful in cases if
your fob battery has died or the circuit
board has been damaged you'll still be
able to start the engine by holding the
key up to the start button and pressing
[Music]
it however it also mean because the
buttons don't work and the the ability
to send the signal here doesn't work
means the circuit board is either
damaged or more likely it's the wrong
circuit board it's for vehicles that
have
fcci ID ending in d02 so that's why it's
really important to verify the fcci ID
number of your original key I recommend
grabbing your phone zoom in snap a photo
and then if you look carefully you will
see the FCC ID in this case it ends with
the letter d01
now what if you don't have an OEM key
you're not going to have the fcci listed
the thing to do there is to call the
dealership ask for the parts department
tell them the VIN number of the vehicle
and ask them what key you need tell them
you need to find out the fcci ID if it
ends in d01 or d02 if they don't give it
to you try calling another monster
dealership you may have to try two or
three they just want you to come in and
get ripped off check out my video where
I demon rate that with hidden cameras so
the good news is this key with blue tag
is always an emergency backup and the
bad news none of the buttons work and
it's pretty inconvenient come to tomsk
key.com where you can save hundreds of
dollars and make a spare key without
leaving your driveway